[موسيقى]
ما يجعل القاهرة فريدة من نوعها هو أنها
تتمتع بتاريخ رائع ومزيج من الثقافات
والتراث الذي نشأ هنا شكّلنا
كثيرًا ألهمني تشغيله ، سأمتلك
قاعدة أنا كلانا الأختان
وراء المصري  ماركة الأزياء القائمة على أوكتان
أعتقد أن علامتنا التجارية هي الحمض النووي الخاص بنا
ويرتبط حمضنا النووي ارتباطًا وثيقًا بجذورنا المصرية
عندما بدأنا لأول مرة في عام 2013
، وكنا نبحث عن الإلهام لذلك
قررنا الذهاب إلى القاهرة القديمة
لماذا الشارع هو قلب  كلتا
القاهرة تنبعث منها طاقة قوية وسلمية ،
كلانا نحب حقًا المشي
هناك الكثير من التاريخ هناك نحن هنا
في الجرح العرقي للمدرسة ،
إنها في الأساس مؤسسة إسلامية
تم بناؤها في القرن الثالث عشر ، لقد
أحببناها كثيرًا هنا يمكنك  تنفس ، تعلم
أن الهندسة المعمارية نفسها تتنفس
وهي ذات طبقات تمامًا ، فهذه واحدة من
أركاننا المفضلة لديك مزيج
بين نقش النخيل والزهرة
الممزوج بالزجاج الملون
والخط الذي يقف خلفه حتى
عمود الجرانيت  لارس من المعابد من الأقصر وأسوان ،
إنها جميلة تمامًا بالطريقة التي يجتمع بها كل شيء ،
يعتقد معظم الناس دوليًا أن
مصر هي الأهرامات أو
الفراعنة وأردنا حقًا الخروج من هذه
الكليشيهات لذلك بدأنا في البحث عن
الإلهام في مكان آخر وعندما فعلنا ذلك
لقد تعلمنا الكثير عن الجلود ، لقد
تعلمنا الكثير عن النحاس ، وقد
ألهمنا هذا حقًا ودفعنا إلى أخذ
هذه الثقافة والتراث وإعادة
تعريفها بطريقة ما ، ولذا فأنا أحمل براحة
قلبنا
نحن هنا في ورشة النحاس
التقليدية وكما  يمكنك أن ترى أن الحرفي
هنا بدأ جدًا في مرحلة
رسم التصاميم ، لذا
فإن اللحام الذي قالوه جميعًا أن
تلميع كل شيء يحدث هنا
يعتبر النحاس تقليديًا جدًا
للثقافة المصرية بشكل عام وهو
يعمل منذ 25 عامًا حتى الآن.
إنه مجرد تراث تم
تناقله من جيل إلى
آخر
بمشاركة قصة من نحن
وإظهار ثقافتنا وتقاليدنا
معًا و  إنه دائمًا ما يعود إلى
أسابيعنا ، وهذا ما يمنحنا Drive كل
صباح ليس فقط لنجعل أنفسنا
بدلاً من جعل مشكلة الأمة بأكملها
[موسيقى]